this is a production of cornell
university
thank you all for being here i mean this
is quite an experience even setting up
this thing
thank you david for the nice
introduction and for the invitation and
i'm not sure if adam's in the audience
but thank you for the initial invitation
for organizing my visit
and uh i would like to also thank some
of my previous professors
for showing up today like tom you were
on my a exam that david brought up
it was a nice experience you know i had
uh really dreaded it but you know all
the professors were very nice
and it's really nice to be back here
it's not easy to get to ithaca but it's
really nice to be here all right
yeah so today i'd like to tell you about
a new research direction
sorry i changed the title i forgot about
the title that i gave like a year and a
half ago
so today i would like to first give a
very brief introduction a brief overview
of our work on micrornas and then go on
to talk about some of the new research
directions
so my experience in david's lab really
instilled in me appreciation for rna not
only as an information carrier but also
as the nexus of gene expression
and you know now you all know that many
processes occur at the rna level and
these processes then bear on the
translatability stability and maybe the
subset of the vocalization of rnas and
thus these processes impact gene
expression
oh i guess i need to move this thing huh
oh yeah so yeah thank you maureen
do i turn this off
top left of that box sorry right
[Music]
oh
thank you thank you
so um
so when you know my my experience in
david's life really you know made me
appreciate the power of rna then i did
my postdoc with uh elliot myers working
on flower developments and i had to say
for like four years rna did not come up
so all of the players in flower
development at the time were
transcription factors and i was very
interested in
genes that
look small it's not frequency
so i was really interested in genes that
patterned the reproductions in the
flower
so these reproductive organs in the
center
the gene the only gene known at the time
was against you can see that in this
mutant the flower doesn't have
reproductive organs the reproductive
organs are transformed
petals and staples
so what i did was to take advantage of a
weak a gamma solute at the time that had
still these male reproductive organs the
statements and i did the mutagenesis
screen the ems screen to look for
genes that help pattern the
reproductive organs and this screen
led me to two genes which are named for
one and part two
and this uh these two genes basically
landed me my first position
and in my
own group we decided to take advantage
of this double mutant power and part two
to conduct another genetic screen to
look for more genes that
pattern the reproductive organs in the
flower so what we did was to mutagenize
this and look for enhancers that would
enhance the floral meiotic phenotype as
you can see in some of these mutants the
stamens are transformed to petals
and most interestingly when we clone
these genes we found that many of them
actually are in
a players in rna metabolism so this
brought us back to the rna world
particularly this gene called n1
so when we cloned this gene we realized
that the protein is a so-called pioneer
protein with unknown function at the
time
and but it does animal homologs even
some
homologs in bacterial species
and it was the
single mutant phenotype that gave us the
clues to the molecular function of this
protein
at the time another dog elliot in
elliot's lab steve jacobson was working
on a mutant called craft and these two
phenotypes i realized are so similar and
um kaf turned out to be dicer like one
one
like proteins in arabidopsis this made
me
realize that maybe both genes actually
act in smartnew metabolism implants so
at the time there were no known small
rnas so we went about cloning the first
few micrornas from plants and then we
looked to see whether these rnas are
gone or reduced in abundance in the hang
one or the path mutant and that was the
case so this led us right back to the
rna world and then we went on to show
that the reason heng 1 mutates to the
fluorophobiatic phenotype that we saw is
most likely because of this mycarnate so
it turns out that this microrna is a
repressor of at2 which is a very
important gene in floral
in specifying the petal identity in
flowers
so that was in the early 2000s and we
decided to make a switch from studying
flower development to study rnas because
my rnas were just known at the time and
very just you know isolated at the time
very little was known about them
so one of the first questions that we
addressed was how micrornas are made
so we're using molecular genetics
fountains or two mediator and diesel
like one are required for micronutrients
and it's very easy to put these proteins
into this pathway just based on their
known molecular functions
but we really stretched our heads on the
molecular function of hand one so what
does that this gene do
and it turns out that we later found out
about chemical smoothies that heng 1
actually is a small metal transferase it
works on a it works on diesel product
it's not sequence specific
and it puts a methyl group onto the 2
prime o h of the three prime terminal
ribose
and
we then went on to show that these two
major types of smarnates plants
um micrornas and si rnas they are
they are they all carry the
reprimand
and because henry has these animal
homologs we also looked into whether
animal micrornas had methyl this metal
group and it turned out that very few of
them actually do
and at the time we didn't find english
but it was very gratifying to see that
many labs showed that pi rnas in animals
are methylated and they're methylated by
hanging homologs
then we looked into what this
methylation leads to micrornas and we
found that in the hang 1 mutant what
happens is that these micrornas become 3
prime truncated or 3-prime uridylated
and at the time when we published this
work in current biology uh guy riddico a
uh editor in
for the journal science picked up our
paper and uh highlighted it and i really
like this title that he gave to his uh
his article so to me instead of you
later on others also showed that
in terms of pi rnas we have named
phenotype basically so in c elegans
tetrahymena drosophila and mutants what
happens is that these pi rnas become
three point truncated and three
polyregulated so this is a conserved
in small rna metabolism
so then this led us to pursue the second
big question in small antibiology and
that is how micrornas are degraded we
presume that these processes lead to
degradation so we looked for the enzymes
that caused a
three prime truncation of micrornas and
three primary regulation of micrornas so
we presume that the exonuclease this
would be a nuclear transference
looked for them using reverse genetics
approaches and we identified a family of
small rna degrading nucleases and we
identified two nucleotidal transferases
that can do this regulation
and by doing biochemistry we showed that
this methyl group really prevents the
activities of these nucleotide
transferases and the
does not completely inhibit sdn enzymes
more importantly we were able to show
that these enzymes can act on
argonaut-bound small rnas remember the
small rnas in vivo they are bound by
arguments and these enzymes can really
work on argonaut bond proteins in mutual
suggesting that they do play a role in
regulating smarny abundance from evil
and i would say that um
related to our
degradation there is
a result that i would like to highlight
and that is sttm so sttm stands for
short tandem target mimic this was a
technology that was developed
collaborator
at michigan tech universities so sttm is
basically a 90 nucleotide or so rna that
can be expressed with any promoter that
you want in vivo and this rna is uh
consists of rna binding sites separated
from the linker and carny binding site
is such that when it pairs with a my rna
it would be a bulge in the middle and
this bulge prevents the micron from
causing cleavage of the stdm rna
so the idea
from the town lab was that they would
express these sttm rnas in vivo to soak
up the cognitive micron it to prevent
the microrna from working on its own
targets but when they introduced the
sttm constructs into plants they saw
that they led to
the reduction of the amount of the
cognitive my partner very specifically
so we suspected that this may be due to
morning degradation so we collaborated
to show that
the stdm rna was actually causing the
degradation of the cognitive microrna
through the sdn exonucleases
and this led us
to the idea that maybe we could develop
a resource for studying my partner
function in people
so what we did was to come up with a
collection of
conserved sttm constructs for conserved
as well as seafood specific micrornas
and we introduced them into rice maize
soybean tomato and arabidopsis and the
stdm technology basically works in all
these plants and you can see here that
you can get specific phenotypic traits
by inhibiting specific
and these constructs are now available
through ad gene
so next uh i would like to go on to talk
about some of the ongoing research and
um i will very briefly talk about our
current research on nassau san nancy
autonomous micrornas and then mainly
focus on this new direction
so micrornas were
known starting from the 2000 year 2000
and in the early years people thought
that
rnas act sell autonomously and they're
so important in patterning so you would
expect them to act self-autonomously
however um in plants at least there has
been increasing evidence that mechanisms
can move from cell to cell and use
systemically and in some circumstances
micrornas have been shown to serve as
signals in developmental patterning for
example in this case this is a diagram
of the arabidopsis root this particular
microrna is only expressed in the
endodermis but it forms a activity
gradient towards the center of the root
and this is transformed into the reverse
gradient of its target gene
and the different levels of expression
of the target gene would lead to
different cell phases in the vasculature
so in in essence this microrna is
functioning as
a morphogen in development
and also in these patterns
there are two small rna gradients one is
a si rna the other is the same micron
here these two gradients help to
specify the two sides of these
and i really like this study this is a
recently published study earlier this
year from jc mass lab what they did was
to do a soybean common bean heavy
and they were able to use the snips
present in these two
species to identify species-specific
small rnas and by doing so they found
basically movement from shoot to root of
a lot of small rnas endogenous srnas as
well as micrornas so they're moving on
mass
whether they all serve as signals we
don't know
but at least you know they are
examples of small rnas serving as
signals in development and in stress
responses impacts
and we realize that very little is known
about how
you know what are the processes that
regulate the cell to cell movement of
small rnas
so we decided to
do our genetic screen to look for
mutants that are compromised in the cell
to cell movement of micrornas so we took
advantage of this line
this is a artificial this line expresses
an artificial micrornas using a
vasculature specific promoter but this
microrna moves out of the site of
synthesis into these mesophyll cells so
that's where you see this uh the
vasculature centered leaf bleaching
because the acid of the artificial
microrna is important for oracle
biosynthesis
so then we neutrogenize this and we look
for mutants that have reduced area of
this bleaching so hopefully some of
those mutants would be
in genes that are important to regulate
the cell to cell movement of micrornas
of course this screen is in specific to
my partner mobility we could get my
carnival genesis mutants for example so
they would show reduced artificial
microrna as well as
levels of endogenous micrornas and we
could screen these out by looking at
this so we keep the ones that have
normal levels of the artificial microrna
and normal levels of endogenous
micrornas either be in my rna activity
or my rna movement so then we do further
experiments to tease them out so right
now we're working with a few of muffins
and we have
some interesting results but i think
today i will instead talk about um
another rich direction so
um you could stay tuned for for
work in this area
so today i would like to talk mainly
about our recent work on rna nad capping
so you all know that um eukaryotic mrnas
carry a m7g cap so this is a methodology
attached to the first phase first
nucleotide of the rna through a 5 prime
to 5 prime triphosphate linkage
and this
cap obviously is very important for rna
metabolic processes but in recent years
alternative tasks have emerged
and these are really interesting
molecules there are
basically cellular metabolites
i think the sheer fact that these
cellular metabolites could serve as mrna
caps suggests that cellular metabolism
could intersect with rna metabolism
and today i'm going to
basically refer nad plus and nadh caps
as the rna nad cap
can be distinguished but
the profiling approaches that i'm going
to talk about cannot effectively
distinguish the two
and also please
metabolize they are all atp analogues
and this is important
when it comes to how these caps are
deposited onto rna because they are atp
analogues they can be incorporated into
rna
by rna polymerase as the initiating
nucleotides
so they're used in place of atp
in fact it was shown in vitro that
bacterial rna polymerases mitochondrial
rna polymerase and yeast pal2 can all
use nad in neutral as they initiate the
nucleotide
in fact
structural studies using bacterial rna
polymerase and the dna template strand
in red and the nadrna showed
um the
you know the nad probability is actually
well coordinated by the active center
amino acids in the army polymerase
because of the co-transcriptional
deposition in bacteria it has been shown
that nad rna production
the efficiency of nad rna packing is
related to the promoter sequences
and in human there's some evidence that
there may be post-transcriptional nad
caching as well but the mechanism is
unknown
so the nad card was first found
by david news group in 2009 so what they
did was to
take bacterial rna
remove the small molecule fraction and
then digest the macromolecular fraction
by nucleus p1 so that now you have
nucleotides and then they subjected the
nucleotides to lcms analysis and they
found nad and further analysis showed
that the nad was actually at the very
fire command of the rna
so we
used developed a similar lcms approach
to see whether arabidopsis rna contains
nad
and indeed we were able to find nad from
both total rna and mrna
and if you look at the amount of id in
total rna versus mrna you can conclude
that nad is primarily in mrna
so this approach
tells you that there is an ad in rna but
it doesn't tell you which rna species
contains the nad path
and this was the development of a
revolutionary approach to
sequence nad packed rnas that was
developed in 2015. so in this nad
capture seek what they did was to
convert first the nad rna
into a alkyne rna using an enzyme adtrc
and the alkyne and then the second step
would be a quick chemistry reaction
where the alkyne rna
work
reacts with the biotin azide to generate
inhalated rna and then the biotinated
rna can be purified and sequenced
so using this approach uh it found that
bacteria yeast and human cells contain
nadcapped rnas so i will refer to
nadcapped rnas as mrna from now on
and using a similar approach my lab and
brian gregory's lab showed that plants
also have madrids
so basically this was the same nadrna
capturing approach that i showed in the
previous slide i just wanted to use this
slide to point out that when we do the
sig we also include adprc minus samples
where we live out this enzyme during the
capturing so these would be the rnas
that got non-specific attached to the
beads
and we did the sequencing with uh
adopted inflorescences and seedlings in
replicas
and then by comparing the amount of
the read counts of the adp-rc plus as
compared to the adplc minus samples we
were able to identify thousands of
genes that produce nad rnas and there
was a good overlap
between the two types of tissues
so where are these nad rnas from
we found that they're mainly from
nuclear the nuclear genome and
and if you take a look at the browser
views it's very easy to see that these
nad rnas are properly spliced
so here are
the adprc plus tracks and the adprc
minus tracks which are very clean and
you can see that the introns are removed
and
most nad rnas are also polyadenylated
so here we did an adrna capture followed
by rtq pcr with either random primers or
the oligodt primer and you can see that
we get the same amount of nad rnas for
these genes
and we also looked into this at the
genomic scale so we first isolated poly
a rna and then we did nad capture c and
compared that to total rna and you can
see that here we're practice plotting
the adprc plus minus ratio to represent
the levels of nad rnas and you can see a
very good concordance
and here i wanted to also highlight the
nad taxi from my collaborator in gcf
from hong kong baptist university so
i thought this was a very innovative
approach
they
they converted nad rna basically
eventually to a chimeric rna containing
this tag rna so the the first step in
the capture is the same you convert
nadrna to this alkyne
and then the second step instead of
using biotin azide they used azide
covalently linked to this tag rna so
then in the end you end up getting this
chemeric rna and then they could subject
the library to a nanopore single
molecule sequencing so in nano for
single molecule sequencing you start
from the three prime end of the rna so
when you sequence and you get the tag
rna sequence then you know that the
original rna was nad rna
so
advantages to an ad taxi
one is that you can actually derive the
ratio of nad rna versus non-adrna
so if you
think about
two types of rnas from any gene nadrna
and m7grna
after the tagging the nad rna contains
the tag rna but the m7g rna does not
then you can either capture the nadrna
through a oligonucleotide dna
oligonucleotide that's complementary to
the tag rna or you can just directly
sequence this mixture if you directly
sequence this mixture then obviously you
could get the ratios of the nad rna and
n7grna
so when they did this they estimated
that nad rna is about five percent of
m7grna but i will tell you that this is
a huge underestimate when it comes to
some genes later on
and another advantage of this nad taxi
is that you can get fullness
sure that these nad rnas are spliced and
polyadenylated
and interestingly they found that the
nad rnas have the same three prime utr
but shorter fibre utr compared to m7g
rnas so despite having short fibrin utr
the nad rnas appear to have the same
coding potential as m7g rnas
so then we wondered whether nad rnas are
translated
this is not a very easy question to
address so we turn to a simpler question
that is whether nad rna is a polysome
associated so we um
get
we got arabidopsis polyzones and we
isolated the polysomal rna and then
we subjected the polynomial rna to an ad
capture c
and we used total rna isolated at the
same time uh for comparison and here i'm
plotting the ssr here by comparing adprc
plus minus
you can com you can derive the nad
armies and you can see that we see a lot
of nad rnas on polysomes
here i'm plotting the adplc plus minus
ratio to represent the levels of the
media rnas and you can see that in the
polysomal fraction we actually see
higher
adprc plus minus ratio suggesting that
we see preferential polysome association
for nad rnas
so are they actually associated with
translating ribosomes so for this we
turn to the
treatment with thermizing so pure mycin
splits translating ribosomes to
ribosomal subunits as you can see that
the treatment works the polysomal
fraction is reduced upon the
monosomal fraction is increased
so then we isolated rna from these
different fractions and we performed an
adcap we performed nad rna capture and
then real-time rt-pcr
so here basically we're looking at
mock-treated samples you can see this uh
significant enrichment of the nad rna in
the polysomal fraction as compared to
the non-polysomal fraction
but upon pyramiding treatment this um
this is you don't see that enrichment
anymore or you even see the movement of
the nad rna into the non-polysomal
fraction so this suggests that nad rnas
are associated with translating
ribosomes
so during our um
efforts in nad rna programming we
realized some issues with nad capture c
and we sought to develop new methods to
profile nad rnas and i'd like i'm going
to talk about this new spark and adc
so we looked at our nad capture seek
read coverage along genes
so this is the gene body coverage of
these and we see this five prime schemes
in the adprc plus samples and we usually
don't see that with rna-seq or with the
adp-rc minus samples which are shown by
the dotted lines
and we thought about this and we
realized that that's because of copper
so in the nad capturing scheme the first
step is to turn nad rna into alkyne rna
and the second step uses this copper
catalyzed click chemistry reaction to
turn our rna into biotin rna
but copper ions are known to degrade rna
to fragment rna so when you have rna
fragmentation together the capturing of
the five prime end of the rna you would
have this five prime skill in the cops
in in the read coverage
also what this means is that you will
have a lot of rna degradation going on
during your uh converting an adrna to
biotin rna so we decided to improve upon
an id capture seek
so this is the quick chemistry it's
called
copper catalyzed alkyne azide
cycloaddition reaction i will refer to
this as the coolac reaction so here what
we do is to use adprc
to basically convert the nad rna to this
alkyne rna and then they have this click
chemistry chemical reaction to generate
biotin rna
and there is a second
popular click chemistry reaction called
spark
stream promoted inside alkyne circular
addition reaction so here my
understanding is that the alkyne being
in
cyclic form um ring form
there's strain in it and the strain
would allow the reaction to occur in the
absence of any catalyst
so we thought that we should adopt this
click chemistry reaction to do an adrna
capture
so remember in the previous reaction
they appended nad rna to this alkyne but
this alkyne is very bulky in this spot
reaction so we thought that maybe we
should try to append the rna to the
azide using adprc
so can we do that we need to first
show that this works
so if this works then we would use a
biotin type alkyne to generate
biotinylated rna
so we looked into this by
first reacting nad and alkyne or nad
with azide in the presence of adprc and
then we would look at the product using
lcms to show that indeed we have the
right product so indeed that was the
case so adprc could catalyze the
reaction between nad and the a-side
so then we
tested this with arabidopsis rna
so we what we do here is we take either
total rna or mrna we perform these
reactions to turn the rna into biotin
rna and then we run the rna in the gl
and then we detect the rna using
streptavidin hrp so the signals that you
see here represent biotinylated rna
so let's first take a total rna so you
can see that
with the spark reaction the sizes of the
rna are much larger than those with the
cloak reaction this is consistent with
the
lack of rna degradation in this back
reaction
but you may also notice that in the
in the negative controls so even without
adprc we still see signals and these are
mainly ribosomal rna and this is because
ribosomal rnas perhaps have some
modifications that could also lead to
the biotin conversion
this is not the problem with mrna so
with arabidopsis mrna the negative
control lanes are very clean
and you can see that with the spark
reaction we got much much stronger
signals as compared to the clock
reaction so we were very excited when we
saw this result but our excitement
lasted maybe five minutes then we
realized that could it be that we are
having an issue maybe uh what we thought
we what we were doing was to convert nad
rna to biotin rna but maybe m7g rnas
were also reacting that'd be a problem
and i should mention that nad capture c
was initially developed for e coli rna
but it was you know adapted to
eukaryotic rna without extensive quality
control to see whether m7g rnas also
react
so we decided to look into this
so if m7g rna can react so we took
m7gppa
to represent m7g rna and then we
performed the reaction with adprc and
the
the azide
and we would expect if the reaction
works then we would get m7g which we
could detect by lcms
and indeed we were able to detect m7g to
our disappointment and this actually
happens
no matter whether you use the azide or
the alkyne
in the reaction so basically the
original nad capture c had the same
issue
but what's really nice is that
this these peaks are pretty small as you
can see it's very close to the baseline
suggesting that this is not a very
efficient reaction
so we wanted to look to
the efficiencies of nad rna capture or
deficiencies of
rna biotinylation
for nadrna and m7grna
so what we did was to in virtual
translate transcribe a nad rna and
m7grna of different sizes then we mix
the two
at different molar ratios and then we
conducted the reactions and you can see
that indeed at this higher and 7g rna
ratio we could see that the m7grna is
converted to biotin rna
um but luckily you know the this the
efficiency is much lower than for nad
rna
and we suspect that this was also going
on even for the kuac reaction but maybe
because of rna degradation we cannot
clearly assign a bend to the m7g rna
so then we thought that we should try to
remove m7g rnas in the before sequencing
so we tried to see whether this
commercially available anti-anxiety
antibody would work
so what we do what we did was to
perform a forming virtual transcription
and then we mix 100 nanograms of nad rna
with 10 micrograms of m7g rna in vitro
and then we
either not treat it not treat the
samples or treat the samples with m7g
bees
afterwards we would perform the spark
reaction detect uh
rna
so
without any treatment you would see the
nad rna and the m7g rna being
biotinylated
but after the m7g
do not see the m7g rna signal anymore so
we were able to
remove the m7g rna
so next we tried this with arabidopsis
rna so we took arabidopsis mrna and then
did either mock treatment or
m7g treatment and then we digested the
rna into nucleotides and we looked at m7
gppa as a readout for m7g rna and nad as
a readout for enable rna
so basically in the flow through
we see about 80
reduction of the m7g rna and we do not
see any reduction
in the nad rna by this m7g antibody
so according to our calculations this
should take care of the problem of m7g
rna interfering with the or
contaminating the nad rna profiling
so basically now we
we have uh developed this uh spark and
nadine using the spark reaction
and also combining this with m7g rna
depletion and you could do that with
either the spark reaction or the coolac
reaction
and we were able to show that the spark
reaction gave higher nad rna signal as
well as better gene body coverage so
this is with the coolac reaction you see
the five prime skill but with the spark
reaction you have better gene body
coverage and you can see that better for
individual genes as well this is the
kuac reaction this is the spark reaction
and this is the regular rna-seq
so from a
developed spot in adc with m7g rna
depletion we got some gene you know gold
terms for the genes that produce nad
rnas and a lot of these are
so-called response genes so these are
involved in environmental responses
and the original nad capture seek also
identified a lot of the response related
gold terms
except for this gold term that is
photosynthesis we now think that this is
probably not these are probably not
really nad rnas
the photosynthetic genes are expressed
at very high levels and i think in this
case these genes showed up probably
because the m7g rnas came up in the in
the capture scheme
and my collaborator also upgraded their
nad taxi to nad taxi too using the spark
approach and here they applied and they
detected two bacterial rnas and i wanted
to make two
points here one is that they looked at
the stationary phase versus the
exponential phase and they were able to
show that
for the same genes the the amount of nad
rna differs between the two growth
phases suggesting that nad rna
production is regulated
and another point that you want i wanted
to make is that for some genes the
percentage of nad rnas in the total
transcript pool can be very high it can
be up to 70 percent
so
for these genes we presume that the nad
rna capping plays some roles in
regulating the expression
so then the question is
what is the molecular or biological
function of rna nad capping
i think we're still in the early days
we
i think there's still a lot to be done
but there are some uh conclusions that
can be made for example in e coli
it was shown that the nad cap stabilizes
rna the rna with the nadcap is more
stable than rna without the nad tab
eukaryotes is the opposite so in a human
cell line for example nadrna when when
the nadrna was transfected into the cell
line it had shorter half-life compared
to m7g rna and
the half-life depends on the enzyme
called dxo which i will talk about next
and here i also wanted to mention that
in this particular study they
transfected mcd luciferase rna and nad
lucifer's rna into the human cell line
and they did not see any lucifer is
being made from the nad rna
so it seems like at least from this
study the nad cap does not support
translation but remember i was telling
you that in arabidopsis nadrnas are
found on polyzones so i think this
aspect of things is still controversial
we still need to figure out whether
individual nadrnas are transmitted
so in terms of options of an adrnas i
think uh studying
the nad deleting enzymes or denied
enzymes would be effective too
so there are actually two major classes
of nadd tapping enzymes one is called
dso so dxo actually takes out the entire
nad moiety from the rna leaving a
5-prime phosphate rna
and the dxo mutant has very severe
phenotypes
so dxo actually has two activities first
is this denominativity
second is that it has five prime to
three prime exonuclease activity that
acts on 5-prime monophosphate rna so
presumably dx could
degrade nadrna by first detecting and
then degrading the rest of the rna in
fact my collaborator eg sas lab showed
that when they transfected a um
nad capped lucifer's rna into wild-type
cells they see very small very very they
see a very fast degradation of the rna
but the half-life is longer in the dxo
mutant protoplast suggesting that indeed
in protoplasts dxo helps to degrade
nadrna
so how about in vivo implanta
a work from brian gregory and johanna
kufo's lab showed very interestingly
that
in the absence of dxo
many genes actually now produce small
rnas endogenous sir phase so the idea is
that in the absence of dxo rnai actually
is used as a backup to degrade these
rnas so in fact
this is a major
rnai enzyme in implants
and in fact when you make a double
mutant between dcl4 and dxo you get very
severe phenotypes seedling lethality
basically
so it seems like dxo is
to degrade some
nad rnas but in the absence of dxo rnai
can help to some extent
however i think here there's still a lot
to be done
um if you look at a dxo mutant that's
transformed with a catalytic mutant of
you see pretty much
rescue good rescue of the phenotype
so whether in vivo dxo
really has this denied inactivity or
whether the denial activity is really
relevant to the phenotype we don't know
yet
so a second class of
nad rna detecting enzyme is uh
represented an e coli node c so this is
a ludics domain protein and interrupt
also the lute c actually has a different
activity from dxo so it removes the nmn
uh nicotinamide moiety of the nadrna
again leaving a five prime monophosphate
rna
so if you look at the nudex family this
is a pretty family in arabidopsis of 29
also members and in fact the famous uh
dcp2 which is the m7gd capping enzyme is
a nudist family protein
so we looked for a aud homolog or
ortholog in arabidopsis and it appears
to be nudg 19.
and uh i'm not sure if i have the time
uh maybe not
so i won't show you the enzymatic
activity assets that we did
but we showed that indeed it has a nad
rna ioping activity in vitro
so then um what what are the phenotypes
of npt19 mutants so there is apparently
a null mutant
in which um
there's no protein that could be
detected
and this mutant looks very normal
however
upon stress so these knocked down and
non-potentials they seem to be more
tolerant stresses so i think maybe nudt
19 is more response related in terms of
development related
so i think i will stop here
and summarize what i told you so
basically we found that narna is a
widespread in the transcriptome
and uh it appears that individual nad
rnas are less stable than m7g rnas
and we've found that nad rnas are
associated with translating ribosomes
and we have identified these two
detaching enzymes and i think studying
these decapping enzymes would lead to
understanding of the molecular and
biological functions of nadrnas so these
are some of the questions that we will
be addressing in the near future are
these nad rna fully translated and what
are the biological processes regulated
by rna and decapin
and um
like to thank the people involved in
this year
most importantly egcr we have been
collaborating in the past uh three to
five years on developing this new
sequencing procedure and on the uh
detaching essays and brilliant i
mentioned developed the sttm technology
we are collaborating with karen brown to
look at the translation of nadrnas in
the wheat journal system
and these are
former former former graduate students
and two current postdocs who contributed
to this work and i would like to thank
the ucr metabolomics core facility as
well uh the lcms was done there okay
well thank you for your attention and uh
thank you guys also who participated via
zoom
i'm not sure whether the zoom questions
can be monitored
yeah i want to give first shot to people
in the room can i get in the background
there
andrew
[Music]
yeah yeah very good questions so so
andrew was asking whether we looked at
uh proteins that bind the nad cat and
whether the translation initiation
factors bind them
so we yeah we did uh in which so we
incubated nad rna and m7 grna with
extracts did the pull down and
mass effect analysis and of course these
analyses you get a lot of proteins so
we're still combing through them
so then
it's possible that we could identify
some readers of nad this way in terms of
the initiation initiating factor
initiation factors we um
we look at them uh individually for
example ef4e and
eif2
they they're very sticky so they bind uh
in vitro to not only m7g rna and adrna
they also bind five prime tpp rna so we
haven't been able to get the assets to
work yeah yet
over there
yeah it's like a lot of decaffeinates at
the end but it's
like a pathway for the
ah so the capping so far it's thought to
be done by rna polymerase so rna
polymerase uses nad as the initiating
nucleotide and this is studied much
better in you in prokaryotes in e coli
they were able to show that the promoter
the transcription start sites really
matter for example the first nucleotide
has to be a because nad is an atp
analog and the minus one position
as well as the plus one position the
moiety actually can pair with the dna
non-template strand
uh so
so yeah so the uh
there are i'm sure there are features
that
this that determine nad capping
efficiency
uh i cannot see this very well my old
eyes so
this is first this is better
or i can read it
and micron targets oh
um you know whether microrna targets are
preferentially nad cap
we haven't actually looked into that
yeah we don't know
tom
um
whether whether maybe the maybe the
catalytic mutant version was complexing
for example with the dx01-2 protein oh
that's a possibility yeah yeah
right
um
yeah this goes back
right right um no no no i mean it's a
catalytic no for sure but the dxo 1-2
uh i think it's a td it has a tdna
insertion somewhere but i don't know
whether it's a complete no yeah great
this goes back to your east genetics
course
[Laughter]
this is a really nice
um
um
um and you also mentioned that
anything
[Music]
yeah so i i think so
uh i think the question is whether
because nad is a redox and energy agent
so could it be that
nad rnas are used as a sensor for the
redox state for example energy state of
of the cell i think it's possible
in fact brian gregory's lab showed that
in dxo mutants for example uh a lot of
the nad metabolic enzymes these genes
are induced
so there seems to be crosstalk with the
nad metabolism the nad rna metabolism
may have crosstalk with the cellular
metabolite metabolism yeah
i got a little confused here maybe with
your diagram how the directionality of
the energy cap
is that a 500
direction
yes you mean the you mean the
place the position of the nad yeah yeah
so this is the
this is the nad and then this is the
first the i mean this or the second
nucleotide of it so the rna would go
like that so this is the first position
yeah so this is the n and n point and
then this is the a
okay so the normal
yeah yeah the rest of the rna is just
rna yeah okay okay
um
[Music]
okay
so aside from photosynthesis which you
would argue with
artifacts what other rights what other
geology
yeah so these are
the first one is actually response to
cadmium ion
so we actually are looking into
a cadmium sensitivity of these decapping
enzyme mutes
yeah so that's something we're looking
into and then there's also response to
bacteria
response to light there's a lot of
response related genes
uh margaret um
[Music]
um
we actually have not that's yeah it's
very that's hard to do because this this
uh the capturing approach the sequencing
you cannot work with a lot of samples at
the same time
but the iod
mutant
uh has a circadian defect
i cannot get one question because your
hand
so you showed all these uh these
polystyrene association it seemed pretty
convincing on a on a whole genome level
that these rnas were ribosome associated
and yet you balance that against like
one luciferase transfection experiment
in human cells or something
so what other explanation is there for
the polystyrene results that you got
well you know one caveat is that the
that was done with nad capture seek
where we did not do m7g rna depletion so
we wonder whether maybe um m7g rnas were
causing the problem or
being actually captured there so we
actually um
evaluated that
so we
we actually took uh basically here the
blue genes in the
uh preferentially translated genes and
the green ones are
polysomnated genes so we actually took
these two groups and looked at their
nadrna levels and we don't really see a
difference so this would argue against
m7g rnas contributing to this but still
i think we now need to go back to do m7g
rna depletion and then the spark
reaction so we'll see
andrew
yeah so that's the that's the idea for
um so what that was from nad tax seeks
so from nanopore single molecule
sequencing um however
because you know remember you know in
the in the constitutional scheme
you have this bulky
uh you know chunk of stuff between the
rna and the tag rna so because of that
the
nanopore cannot you cannot call
precisely the site of trans
transcription initiation so you can only
say maybe it's within these 10
nucleotides or so and at that position
at that level
we could definitely say that m7g rnas
have longer 500 utrs but we cannot say
where is the initiating
side for nadr
right right for for a lot of the genes
yes
because you see a lot of responses
quietly
he said i was wondering whether it is
possible that
um
those genes have h2s
because
um
[Music]
uh the question is whether these nad
capped rnas are from genes that are h2az
in which because h2az is this uh
variant that's associated with uh
response or stimulus with response
related uh genes and uh we haven't
looked into that but yeah that could be
something into yeah
yeah i think um in the interest of time
and thanks for yeah we knew you lost a
lot of time to technology but thanks for
bearing with it let's thank you again
for it
thank you
[Applause]
yeah thank you all for being here in
person it's great to see you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu